[Musik]
Kopf an Kopfhörern in den USA bei den
zwischenzeilen ex-präsent Trump wittert
mal wieder Wahlbetrug Facebook-Chef Max
Zuckerberg entlast 11.000 Mitarbeiter
und in Deutschland entbrennt ein Streit
über noch höhere Steuern für
Topverdiener meine Gäste heute Abend
sind linken Politikerin Sarah
Wagenknecht die ist kürzlich im inser
meinungstrend auf Platz 2 der
beliebtesten Politiker schoss kein
Wunder dass ich jetzt aktuelle viele
Bürger inklusive mir selbst fragen ob
sie eine eigene Partei gründen könnte
schön dass Sie da sind ja weil jahrelang
haushaltspolitischer Sprecher der Union
im Bundestag jetzt fordert er kein
Rehberg gezielt Maßnahmen wieder mehr
Menschen in Festanstellung zu bringen
ich bin gespannt Katharina kühne ist
Chefin einer Bäckerei mit mehreren Läden
sie kämpft mit den gestiegenen
Energiekosten und macht dafür Robert
Habeck verantwortlich auch mit von der
Partie stormy Miltner sie ist Direktorin
des essen-instituts und ruft Deutschland
dazu auf sich selbst mehr um die
Sicherheitspolitik zu kümmern nicht nur
die Außen- und Sicherheitspolitik
beschäftigt uns Frage besonders tut das
auch die Wirtschaft und mein Thema heute
Abend ist Robert Habeck ignoriert
deutsche Interessen wenige Minister
wurden ja in der deutschen
Medienlandschaft so überschätzt wie
Habeck die Grünen werden ja generell
sehr gerne medial gefeiert also die
Marketing Maschinerie braucht eigentlich
auch mal eine andere Partei die Welt
Chefredakteurin Dagmar Rosenfeld hatte
schon vor Jahren treffen auf den Punkt
gebracht damals hat sie gesagt alle 11
Minuten verliebt sich ein
stern-redakteur in einen grünen und so
war es auch eigentlich wieder bei Robert
Habeck als der Wirtschaftsminister wurde
feierte in die journali für seinen neuen
Kommunikationsstil auch die Wirtschaft
sei angetan hieß es gut die Begeisterung
der Wirtschaft die enthielt sich immer
meinem Kenntnisstand aber sei es darum
nun wird jedoch immer klarer Harbeck
ignoriert deutsche Interessen wie komme
ich denn darauf ich komme darauf weil in
seinem Kampf um den Klimawandel nimmt er
den Abstieg der deutschen Wirtschaft
nicht nur in Kauf nein er scheint ihn
sogar für geboten zu halten auch der
Wettbewerbsnachteil in unsere indust
aufgrund der Unterschiede bei den
Energiepreisen zwischen den USA und
Europa erleidet der wird meines
Erachtens nach von ihm gekonnt ignoriert
meine erste Frage geht an Frau
Wagenknecht habe ich Recht habe ich
nicht recht und falls ja warum ignoriert
denn Robert Habeck die deutschen
Interessen so gekonnt ja also gibt es ja
nur zwei Erklärungen also entweder er
durchschaut nicht was er macht oder es
ist ihm egal und natürlich haben die
Grünen eigentlich schon immer so eine
Art Position nur teure Energie ist gute
Energie
ich finde das unglaublich
verantwortungslos und ich finde er
musste auch stärker unter Druck geraten
also es kann doch nicht sein dass diese
Regierung Sehnen Auges im Grunde das
Standbein unseres Wohlstandes kaputt
gehen lässt und das ist ja die Industrie
das ist aber auch das Handwerk das sind
kleine Unternehmen das ist der
Mittelstand und die alle leiden jetzt
unglaublich und andere
Wirtschaftsregionen profitieren davon
und ich finde das geht so nicht und das
darf man einfach nicht weiter hinnehmen
warum spricht Habeck das nicht an der
französische Minister hat es
beispielsweise angesprochen auch die
Unterschiede zwischen Amerika und
Deutschland und Blick auf die
Strompreise die er für uns ein
eklatanten Wettbewerbsnachteil
darstellen warum wird es nicht wirklich
auch mal kommuniziert unter welchen
Wettbewerbsnachteilen wir leiden ja also
es gibt sogar Zitat von Hardeck wo er so
gesagt hat ja also wir müssen jetzt
aufpassen dass wir nicht in ein
Handelskrieg mit Amerika kommen ja aber
der ist ja längst da der wird ja auch
längst geführt mit aller Brutalität und
gerade die Grünen sind da also wirklich
die unterwürfigsten und ein Punkt muss
man auch noch sehen es nützt ja noch
nicht mal dem Klima also gerade wenn wir
jetzt tatsächlich in Größenordnungen und
darauf läuft es ja hinaus amerikanisches
Fracking Gas kaufen in Zukunft das ist
ja nicht nur viel viel teurer als das
Gas was wir vorher hatten sondern das
ist auch extrem umweltschädlich oder
noch ein Beispiel wir haben doch jetzt
habe ich hat ja von der Reste Rampe
dieser Welt diese lng-terminals gekauft
das heißt dieses eine Terminal was jetzt
vor Schleswig-Holstein im Grunde in
Aktionen gehen soll da muss man wissen
das ist umwelttechnisch so schlecht dass
es vorher in Australien nicht eingesetzt
werden durfte weil es so viel Chlor ins
Wasser spült dass das dort tatsächlich
die die Meereslebewesen vernichten würde
und bei den Kohlekraftwerken ähnlich da
gehen jetzt kohlemeile ans Netz die
eigentlich alle Umweltstandards reißen
und gleichzeitig heucheln die Grünen sie
seien die Umweltpartei und ich habe
gerade gehört in München darf man nicht
mehr im Diesel jetzt in die Innenstadt
fahren also das ist so eine verlogene
Politik und ich finde also ich kann mich
da überhaupt nicht genug aufregen und es
ärgert mich einfach dass die immer so
weitermachen können dass sie Teil dieser
Regierung sind dass die anderen
Regierungsparteien das auch hinnehmen
und dulden also ich finde das kann nicht
so weitergehen weil alles was kaputt
gemacht wird das kommt nicht wieder das
muss man einfach auch wissen sie haben
die Grünen ja sogar als gefährlich
bezeichnet wenn ich das richtig in
Erinnerung habe also ich finde dass sie
gemessen an dem was sie an realen
Schaden anrichten aktuell die
gefährlichste Partei sind die wir im
Bundestag haben also da gab es einen
großen Aufschrei die AFD sei
gefährlicher ich finde die AFD also eine
wirklich zutiefst
unschöne und unerfreuliche Partei und
die hat Nazis in ihren Reihen die hat
Rechtsextremisten das finde ich alles
abscheulich aber die AFD kann überhaupt
nicht mehr als reden aber die Grünen
richten richtigen Schaden an sie sie
ruinieren den Wohlstand von Millionen
Menschen sie stürzen sie in die Armut
sie zerstören wenn man sie weitermachen
lässt Kernbereiche unserer Industrie die
dann einfach weg sind der
Industriestandort Deutschland ist in
Gefahr und das ist für mich hoch
gefährlich Herr Ribbeck ist der
Industriestandort Deutschlands in Gefahr
ja ist völlig unabhängig aus meiner
Sicht vom ukrainekrieg in Gefahr gewesen
weil die Grünen das stimmig Frau
Wagenknecht zu verstecken sich ganz
geschickt in der Ukraine Krise um ihre
Ideologie durchzusetzen
und es geht nur aus meiner Sicht noch
ein Stückchen weiter wenn Sie das Thema
Windkraft Solar nehmen kein Mensch redet
darüber welche pachten bezahlt werden
ich komme aus Mecklenburg-Vorpommern für
neue Windenergieanlagen von 56 Megawatt
werden bis zu 100.000 Euro Pacht pro
Anlage pro Jahr bezahlt ich da werden
einspeise vergütungsrenditen im
zweistelligen Prozentbereich erreicht
und Christian Lindner hat nicht umsonst
darauf hingewiesen dass bei dem Thema
zufallsgewinne die Windmüller ganz oben
mit dabei sind aber auch die Medien
spielen natürlich den ganzen
entscheidende Rolle alles was Grünes ist
gut
auch grüne Energie ist immer gut da wird
gar nicht in der fragt und das
Energiethema aus meiner Sicht hat man es
relativ einfach lösen können indem man
die Atomkraftwerke hätte länger laufen
lassen Polen baut neue Schweden
tüchtigt hatten Endlager und so weiter
und was wir über die Jahre versäumt
haben ist uns auf eigene Füße auch im
Energiebereich zu stellen du kriegst in
Deutschland kein sandtagebombe
aufgeschlossen geschweige denn eigenes
Erdöl oder Erdgas gefördert und
lng-terminal hätten wir aus meiner Sicht
schon vor einem Jahrzehnt Wilhelmshaven
hatte Baurecht errichten müssen ähnlich
wie die Spanier zum Beispiel die haben
so etwas oder die Belgier oder die
Holländer und wir sind aus meiner Sicht
da im viel zu große Abhängigkeiten
geraten Frau mit der Serien im Blick von
außen die empfinden sie denn die
deutsche Wirtschaftspolitik erstmal
würde ich ganz deutlich sagen dass die
Krise in der wir uns befinden nicht an
den Grünen liegt sondern an Russlands
Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine und an
den hohen Abhängigkeiten die wir von
Russland hatten und immer ja auch noch
haben in Teilen und dass wir das eben
völlig unterschätzt haben also unsere
hohe Abhängigkeit
verantwortlich machen wollen eher die
Union dann wahrscheinlich fahren ja ich
würde es ich würde gar nicht die Union
alleine verantwortlich machen sondern
das war ein ich würde mal insgesamt
gesellschaftliches und politisches und
auch wirtschaftliches versagen wir haben
halt über Jahrzehnte hinweg geglaubt das
gegenseitige ab dass wir
entgegenseitigen Abhängigkeiten uns
bewegen also wir sind abhängig von
russischem Gas und Öl und Russland ist
eben abhängig von unserem Geld von
unseren Devisen von unserem Euro und
weil sie eben abhängig sind würden sie
uns den Gashahn nicht abdrehen und wir
hatten aber auch die Erfahrung
Vergangenheit waren noch nie ein
Wettbewerbsvorteil also man kann nicht
sagen dass vor dem Krieg Deutschland so
niedrige Strompreise hatte das ist immer
ein Wettbewerbsvorteil war das stimmt
nicht nur habe ich auch gar nicht gesagt
aber unsere Wettbewerbsfähigkeit speist
dich vor allen Dingen auch aus der hohen
Qualität der Produkte die wir eben auch
herstellen aber auch der internationalen
Verflechtung aber um nochmal
zurückzukommen wir haben eben diese
Abhängigkeiten falsch eingeschätzt und
wir haben auch die Rationalität
Russlands falsch eingeschätzt und wir
hätten eben früher darauf reagieren
müssen und früher unsere Energie
Bezugsquellen diversifizieren müssen wir
hatten also viel früher auch am
lng-terminals bauen müssen und auch
wahrscheinlich noch mehr und schneller
auch in Erneuerbare Energien investieren
müssen und wir hatten ja die Debatte
schon mal während der Verhandlung mit
den USA zu Titel zum international also
zum transatlantischen Handels- und
Investitionsabkommen und da wollten wir
alle das LNG nicht so von den USA und
jetzt jetzt hat es uns eben erwischt und
in dieser Krise umzusteuern das ist
natürlich wahnsinnig schwierig und das
das vor der großen Herausforderung steht
eben gerade die Ampelkoalition ich finde
man muss sich aber in der Debatte
ehrlich machen wenn sie sagen in
Erneuerbare Energien investieren erneuer
Technologien müssen grundlastfähig
gemacht werden klar rufen wir das Thema
Wasserstoff auf da habe ich heute ein
nachteilsfaktor zwischen 4 und 8 und
über die Speicherfähigkeit und
Wasserstoff werden wir im nächsten
Jahrzehnt jedenfalls industriell und
wirtschaftsmäßig nicht werden reden
können das heißt wir werden wenn das so
weitergeht jetzt völlig unabhängig noch
mal von dem Thema Ukraine weil der Weg
den haben die Grünen dahin wollen die
beschreiten und und der wird beschritten
werden das heißt unsere Strompreise sind
auch deswegen so hoch weil wir natürlich
ganz stark auf erneuerbare Energien
gesetzt haben und ganz nebenbei kommen
noch mal zu dem Thema pachten und so
weiter zurück diese ganze erneuerbaren
Energien Geschichte ist die größte
vermögensumverteilung der letzten Jahre
und Jahrzehnte in Deutschland von den
nicht Besitzenden zu den Besitzenden
weil die nicht Besitzenden wir alle
bezahlen die erneuerbaren Energien und
wenn sie sich mal die Strukturen
angucken gut es gibt ein paar Windparks
aus Wissenschaften in Schleswig-Holstein
war bei mir zu Hause wird das
überwiegend in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern
über Fonds geregelt wenn man sich
angucken die Investitionen im
Offshore-Bereich dann sind dann die ganz
großen dabei also ich finde diese
Debatte muss ehrlicher gemacht werden
und die hat es nicht nur mit grüner
Ethnologie zu betrachten sondern sie ist
auch industriepolitisch
sicherheitspolitisch zu betrachten an
der Stelle und auch die Zeiträume sorry
finde ich muss man sich auch mal ehrlich
machen das wird nicht alles morgen und
übermorgen realisiert werden können da
werden wir Jahre und Jahrzehnte brauchen
ich glaube sicher ist der Hund das kann
man ja überhaupt nicht bestreiten dass
wir einerseits natürlich langfristig
eine Veränderung brauchen weg von den
fossilen Energieträgern aber
andererseits zur Zeit technologisch
überhaupt nicht in der Lage sind die
Erfordernisse auch die
energieerfordernisse unserer Industrie
mit erneuerbaren Energien abzudecken
also da stimme ich ihn ja völlig zu aber
insoweit war das eigentlich und und
insoweit sind wir abhängig also wir sind
abhängig von denen die uns
Energieträger liefern wir werden auch
zukünftig abhängig sein ja nur weil sie
hat also eigentlich wollte ich auf sie
reagieren und widersprechen gar nicht
auf sie Herr Rewe weil ich finde ist
immer zusammen wir waren wir haben uns
abhängig gemacht wir sind ein
rohstoffarmes Land und wir sind ein Land
das wenig Energieträger hat wir können
mit erneuerbaren Energien ein Teil der
Energieversorgung abdecken aber wir
haben im Bereich der fossilen Energien
Abhängigkeiten wir hätten die
Abhängigkeiten natürlich auch im
Nuklearbereich also war immer gesagt
wird Frankreich steht besser da weil sie
eine weil sie ganz viel Atomstrom haben
ja warum haben sie den Atomstrom
frankreich hat eine intelligentere
Regierung als Deutschland die haben
nämlich darauf bestanden dass alles was
Sie für zum Betreiben ihre Atommeiler
brauchen dass das aus den
sanktionspaketen ausgeklammert wird weil
das Uran kommt zu großen Teilen aus
Russland das angereicherte Rohren und
das wird dann auch wieder nach Russland
zurückgeschickt also die französische
Atomstrom hängt ganz eng an der
Kooperation mit Russland also das sollte
man nicht ganz vergessen wenn man sagt
wir hätten einen anderen Weg einschlagen
können oder einschlagen sollen wir haben
gesagt wir setzen auf Gas das russische
Gas ist konkurrenzlos billig gewesen
sehr viel billiger als das amerikanische
LNG Gas wir haben die Hälfte aus
Russland geholt das war ja eigentlich
schon eine der Diversifizierung und dass
der Gasherd abgedreht wurde ich meine
russland hat seit den 70er Jahren
Deutschland vorher noch Westdeutschland
also selbst im Kalten Krieg zuverlässig
beliefert das hatte ja was mit den
Sanktionen zu tun und deswegen finde ich
ich finde den ukrainekrieg natürlich
auch ein riesiges Verbrechen ich wünsche
mir dass man viel mehr tut um ihn zu
beenden aber die explodierenden
Energiekosten sind nicht die direkte
Folge des ukraine-kriegs sie sind die
Folge dieser sanktionspakete die dann
einen Wirtschaftskrieg begonnen haben
auf den Russland reagiert hat und das
hätte man sich vorher überlegen können
Aktionen man kann noch das Verhalten
Russlands nicht so stehen lassen und
darauf aber wenn dieser ja in Russland
gar nicht schaden sprechen
noch über die Sanktionen ganz
ausführlich ich würde gerne einmal
gebe ich will alle ihre Argumente heute
noch hören aber einmal möchte ich gerne
Sie noch Fragen zu dem Thema Robert
Habeck und der Wirtschaftspolitik als
Praktikerin sie haben eine Bäckerei auch
mit mehreren Filialen wie zufrieden sind
Sie denn mit unserem Wirtschaftsminister
also ich muss sagen absolut gar nicht
zufrieden seit mehreren Wochen kämpfe
ich ganz aktiv mit vielen meiner
Kollegen gegen genau diese hohen Preise
wie wir jetzt entlastet werden sollen
wir haben es geschafft dass wir in der
Politik gehört werden ich selbst konnte
mit Herrn Habig sprechen
und kann einfach nicht nachvollziehen
dass uns nicht geholfen wird und uns das
meine ich wirklich die Lebensmittel
produzierenden Betriebe wir sind
systemrelevant das sind nicht nur die
Bäcker das sind auch die Metzger das
sind die Molkereien wir sollen entlastet
werden beziehungsweise gebremst und
gedeckelt um es mal an diesen Worten zu
sagen der Politik genauso wie
Privathaushalte das ist nicht möglich
ich war sehr erschrocken dass Herrn
Habeck nicht klar war als ich mit ihm
gesprochen habe dass wir ganz andere
Preise bisher hatten als die
Privathaushalte er sagte dann dann sind
sie ja Industrie nein das bin ich nicht
ich bin ein kleines mittelständiges
Unternehmen mit 60 Mitarbeitern aber
natürlich wenn wir mehrere stand also
was heißt Standorte wir haben mehrere
Verkaufsstellen dann habe ich wesentlich
mehr Energie die ich benötige und auch
zum Backen des Brotes brauche ich
wesentlich mehr Energie als zum Heizen
einer vierköpfigen Familie
beispielsweise
ganz klar kann ich bei uns sagen sind
das ungefähr 450.000 Kilowattstunde per
anno und wir kommen ungefähr das gesamte
Bäckereihandwerk von und das ist auch so
was die Politik nicht weiß oder viele
Politiker nicht wissen wie sich
überhaupt der Strom und der Gaspreis
zusammensetzt also ich habe eben immer
gehört wir hatten ja so niedrige Preise
ja der Grundpreis war sehr sehr niedrig
die Umlagen waren schon immer sehr hoch
wir sind zum Beispiel auch nie
ausgenommen wurden von der EEG-Umlage
aber um es mal in der faktisch zu sagen
wir kommen von einem Gaspreis der bei im
Schnitt zwei Cent der reine Arbeitspreis
dann kam Anfang von 2,4 Cent obendrauf
so dass der Bäcker im Schnitt 5 Cent
maximal gezahlt hat und wir sollen jetzt
gedeckelt werden bei 12 Cent wegen also
die Mehrwertsteuer noch abgezogen das
heißt wir sind dabei einer Verdopplung
und beim Strom ist es exorbitant also
beim Strom kommen wir von dem
Arbeitspreis von vier Cent und sind dann
brutto mit allen Umlagen im Moment bei
15 sind das sieht man mal wie das ist
also der große Teil sind wirklich
Steuern Steuern steuern ohne die
Mehrwertsteuer und wir sollen jetzt auf
40 Cent minus Mehrwertsteuer das heißt
37 Cent da ist es mehr als eine
Verdopplung wenn das so in die Tat
umgesetzt wird dann funktioniert das
nicht auf Ihr persönliches Beispiel
kommen wir nachher auch noch mal ganz in
Ruhe zu sprechen jetzt machen wir einmal
die These von Frau Wagenknecht aber das
Gefühl habe ich übrigens auch dass viele
Politiker die Wirtschaft gar nicht
verstehen das kann sein da haben Sie
Recht ihre These
ja also Henry Kissinger hat ja mal
sinngemäß gesagt Amerika hat keine
Freunde oder Feinde Amerika hat
Interessen und ich glaube dass es
wirklich an der Zeit ist dass wir das
verstehen dass wir dieses naive Amerika
Bild das sind unsere Freunde dass wir
das dringend korrigieren und unsere
eigenen Interessen sehen und auch unsere
eigenen Interessen verteidigen weil es
sind nicht nur die Republikaner es ist
nicht nur Donald Trump der make America
great again betreibt sondern das macht
die beiden Administrationen ganz genauso
teilweise sogar noch brutaler es kommt
damals also beiden hat im August ein
Gesetz auf den Weg gebracht also in
Kraft gesetzt nachdem die amerikanische
Industrie 400 Milliarden Dollar
Subventionen bekommen soll und zwar
wirklich nur Hersteller in den USA also
eine klare Diskriminierung zum Beispiel
auch für deutsche europäische
Unternehmen die die USA beliefern der
Sinn ist es sollen Arbeitsplätze und
Industrie aus Europa nach den USA
verlagert werden das ist ja Sinn 400
Milliarden dafür beiden hat jetzt ein
jedes Mal eine Verschärfung auch der
china-sanktionen beschlossen also ein
ganz massiven Einschnitt in bestimmte
Branchen die in der Halbleiter in met
Halbleitern Arbeiten amerikanische
Produkte auch verbauen das betrifft auch
europäische Unternehmen de facto läuft
es darauf hinaus Europa von dem
chinesischen Markt abzuschneiden das ist
gerade für eine exportstarke Nation wie
Deutschland ein echtes Problem und wir
sollten begreifen auch die Russland
Sanktionen Schaden Europa mindestens
genauso sehr wie Russland eigentlich
sogar noch sehr viel mehr weil Russland
hat zurzeit sogar mehr Einnahmen als
vorher weil die Preise so explodiert
sind wir haben die hohen Energiekosten
und diese extrem hohen Energiekosten
haben für die USA natürlich ein
positiven Nebeneffekt unsere
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit sinkt da Trump hat
sich immer erregt über die deutschen
Handelsüberschüsse und über die starke
deutsche Exportindustrie das Kapitel ist
bald erledigt wenn wir bei den jetzigen
Energiepreisen bleiben und ganz nebenbei
kann die USA so sogar ein großes
Geschäft Unternehmen nämlich für das
europäische Gas auch für die Belieferung
Deutschlands mit Gas mit teurem Gas also
das alles ist nicht in unserem Interesse
und deswegen glaube ich müssen wir uns
dringend darauf besinnen was hilft uns
was hilft unserer Volkswirtschaft was
ist für die Menschen hier in Deutschland
wichtig und ich finde das sollte schon
die Politik tatsächlich auch bestimmen
Herr Rehberg wie ist es mit unseren
eigenen Interessen macht die Politik
genug für uns selbst muss es vielleicht
sogar mehr heißen MC Germany great again
also die Vereinigten Staaten Amerikas
Freund zu haben und eigene Interessen zu
betreten darin sehe ich kein Widerspruch
überhaupt nicht und ich denke mal gerade
im Westen Deutschlands auch im Osten
muss man den Vereinigten Staaten dankbar
sein über 70 Jahre Frieden und Freiheit
in Europa und auch
wer den Wegbereiter zu Wiedervereinigung
es war nicht mal gezeche das waren die
Vereinigten Staaten unter anderem noch
Frankreich war der eher
ohne den wäre es wohl nicht gegangen
Entschuldigung ohne Michael Gorbatschow
und Helmut Kohl wärs auch nicht gegangen
und Oskar Lafontaine und Gerhard
Schröder haben da keinen großen Beitrag
an der Stelle geleistet ganz im
Gegenteil aber nochmal zu diesem
wirtschaftlichen Thema zurückzukommen ja
klar es gibt drei große Komponenten auf
die unser Wohlstand mitberührtes eine
ist wir haben jährlich zwischen 20 und
30 Milliarden Euro zu wenig in den
letzten Jahren ausgegeben für
Verteidigung Stichwort zwei Prozent
zielt zweitens das ist das billige
russische Gas und drittens Lieferketten
China darauf neben vielen anderen
Faktoren das sind drei Faktoren die man
schon mit dem Auge behalten sollte das
Argument Freiheit und Frieden
durchhandel anstatt Abschottung das
Argument gibt es auch ganz schwieriges
Thema weil ich sag mal diese diese
russischen Rohstoffe liefen auch für den
Osten Deutschlands liefen für den Westen
Deutschland seit Jahren und Jahrzehnten
und sicher
war es nicht vorher besehbar dass Putin
das Russland sehr stark unterstützt von
russischen Bevölkerung 80 Prozent
Zustimmung in ein Aggressionskrieg gegen
die Ukraine fährt übrigens schon seit
2014/15 nicht erst seit dem 24 Februar
diesen Jahres der Krimkrieg begann
bedeuten früher und Frau Wagenknecht ich
finde Sanktionen gehören dazu man kann
nicht die Vergewaltigung von Frauen in
Ukraine tolerieren man kann Butcher
nicht tolerieren man kann nicht die
zwangsdireportation von Kindern
ignorieren und man kann auch nicht die
Zerstörung der zivilstruktur ignorieren
also wenn man wenn man wie sie
argumentiert dann sagt sich Putin doch
ich habe alles richtig gemacht ganz im
gegen nein doch das geht schon auch
darum ich Verbrechen aber wir ändern
daran nicht doch durch die Sanktionen
sind ja höher als vorher das geht doch
nicht nur um die Einnahmen es geht auch
darum es ist doch eine dieser große
russische Staat muss sich
minderwertige Drohnen aus dem Iran
einkaufen weil sie selber nicht in der
Lage sind sowas zu produzieren und und
und gucken uns im Zustand der russischen
Armeen das wirkt schon aus meiner Sicht
dieser Sanktionen und kommen noch den
Ausgangspunkt zurück was Amerika
betrifft ich finde ja wir müssen eigene
und wo es möglich ist auch europäische
Interessen gemeinsam wahrnehmen wenn ich
zum Rohstoffbereich komme dann müssen
wir auch mal über unseren eigenen
Schatten springen beginnend beim Kies
und sandtagebau angefangen bis hin zu
seltenen Erden wir haben Seltene Erden
in Deutschland zum Beispiel Lithium dann
müssen wir daran gehen die selber zu
erschließen und nicht nur von chinons
abhängig zu machen und auch vom Erdgas
und Erdbeben wir einmal bei dem Vorwurf
damit Frau Wagenknecht darauf auch
antworten kann sie haben ja eigentlich
unterstellt dass Frau Wagenknecht mit
ihrer These die Vergewaltigung butschter
und Co tolerieren würde ich habe ehrlich
gesagt
dann dann würde das Putin das auffassen
nee das habe ich so immer vorsichtig
diese Verbrechen dieses Krieges klar
verurteilen ich finde auch dass wir viel
mehr tun müssten um diesen Krieg auf
diplomatischen Weg zu beenden und damit
natürlich auch das Sterben und das
Leiden zu beenden das ist überhaupt
nicht die Frage die Frage ist ob diese
Sanktion irgendein sinnvollen Beitrag
dazu leisten das sehe ich nicht und ich
meine meine Kollegin sehr wem dadelen
hat vor kurzem die Bundesregierung
gefragt ob sie irgendwelche belastbaren
Erkenntnisse hat dass die Sanktionen
einen Einfluss auf den Kriegsverlauf
haben und die Antwort der
Bundesregierung war ganz knapp nein wir
haben keine Erkenntnisse ja man kann
doch nicht riesige Sanktionen die uns
selber massiv Schaden aufrechterhalten
ohne irgendwie ein Argument zu haben
dass es den Kriegsverlauf und die
Verbrechen bei dem Krieg auch nur
beeinflusst und das zweite was ich dazu
sagen will ich finde auch die
Doppelmoral heuchlerisch also es ist ja
nicht so dass wir auf alle
verbrecherischen Kriege dieser Welt mit
solchen Sanktionen reagieren Herr Habeck
fährt in den Nahen Osten herr Scholz
während den Nahen Osten nach
Saudi-Arabien wo also ein seit Jahren
ein furchtbarer verbrecherischer Krieg
gegen den je geführt wird mit ganz viel
zivilen Opfern das ist weiter weg als
die Ukraine aber das ist für die
Menschen die dort Leiden das 80.000
Kinder bisher umgebracht worden für die
Menschen die darunter leiden ist das
genauso schlimm und da machen wir keine
Sanktion da liefern wir sogar Waffen was
ich nun tatsächlich natürlich für
Russland nicht befürworten würde also
wir sollten natürlich Russland keine
Waffen und keine Drohnen liefern aber
Sanktionen für Düngemittel Sanktionen
für Getreide Sanktionen für Energie auch
für Öl Ende des Jahres hören wir auf
russisches Öl zu kaufen nach Herrn
harbecks Logik oder nach seiner
Entscheidung es ist völlig irre und
damit haben wir auch provoziert dass wir
vom Gas eben abgeklemmt wurden andere
europäische Länder kaufen russisches Gas
übrigens anders als wir also wir sind da
auch besonders dumm und das halte ich
weder von vor dem Gesichtspunkt der
Moralen noch vor irgendwelchen anderen
Kriterien für gerechtfertigt aber sind
die Deutschen Sanktionen zielführend
einmal sie haben machen wir ich
unterstütze die Sanktionen zum einen
weil ich es aus moralischer Sicht
absolut wichtig finde dass Putin etwas
entgegen gehalten wird und was wir sehen
ist ein Verhalten was man einfach nicht
tolerieren kann deswegen erstens aus
moralischer Sicht unterstütze ich die
Sanktion zweitens ich unterstütze dass
sie im europäischen Verbund verhängt
werden und mit unseren Partnern zusammen
also mit den USA und anderen westlichen
Ländern dadurch werden sie auch mehr
Schlagkraft entwickeln dritter Punkt
warum sie noch nicht den Kriegsverlauf
massiv geändert haben ist weil wir bei
bestimmten Bereichen einfach auch nicht
schnell genug waren mit den Sanktionen
und das ist nun mal gerade Öl und ist
nun mal Gas und warum wir da nicht
schneller waren ist weil das eben auch
hohe Kosten für uns verursacht und man
da eine Transition vornehmen muss und
weil andere europäische
EU-Mitgliedstaaten teilweise sogar noch
abhängiger sind und die Abstimmung im
europäischen Verbund hat uns eben an
dieser Stelle etwas langsamer gemacht
aber ist meiner Meinung nach absolut
notwendig und die Beratung da Sanktionen
von einem Tag auf den anderen greifen
das so schnell funktioniert es eben auch
nicht aber deswegen würde ich trotzdem
nicht sagen dass es falsch ist und ich
würde auch sagen letzter Punkt vierter
Punkt dass dass wir auch einen Preis
bereit sein müssen zu zahlen dafür
nämlich einen Preis um unsere Freiheit
und unsere Werte zu verteidigen denn die
Frage ist doch wirklich wo macht Putin
denn letztendlich halt wird er wirklich
bei der Ukraine halt machen oder steht
da als nächstes wer steht denn als
nächstes dann auf seiner angriffsliste
und dem muss man eben etwas
entgegenhalten aber Sanktionen alleine
reichen natürlich nicht aus man muss
weiterhin also man muss auch harte
Waffen liefern das ist auch klar an die
Ukraine und man muss trotzdem auch bei
aller bei aller Härte auch immer die
Gesprächsbereitschaft offen halten aber
im Moment ist da nichts zu sprechen im
Moment geht das nicht und deswegen eben
Sanktionen und Waffenlieferungen an die
ukrainewelt würden sie gehen wenn ich
einmal zusammenfassen aber sie sagen die
wir brauchen einfach noch länger Zeit zu
wirken wenn sie vorher beschlossen
werden wenn hätten sie schon gewirkt und
das zweite ist aufgrund der Moral aber
muss nicht den deutschen Volk auch
gegenüber die Moral gezeigt werden dass
die Sanktionen auch etwas bringen also
gibt es nicht eine Pflicht der Politik
zu zeigen das und das und das und das
bringt der Verzicht bei nur zu sagen die
Moral muss es richten das reicht den
Bürgern ja anscheinend nicht mehr auch
wenn man auf im Umfragen blickt man muss
auf jeden Fall immer erklären was man
macht das ist klar und wofür was auch
machen nämlich für unsere Freiheit und
unsere Werte und dass diese auch zu
verteidigen also verteidigt werden
müssen und wir müssen auch erklären was
die Ukraine im Moment gerade auch für
uns leisten und auch dass es irgendwann
auch darum gehen wird den Wiederaufbau
mit zu finanzieren und auch das wird uns
kosten und das ist richtig dass es uns
was kostet also es braucht einen
letztendlich Marshallplan für die
Ukraine auch und das muss man erklären
natürlich klar da muss man in den
Austausch gehen also ich kann und will
zu den Sanktionen können wir nichts
sagen aus dem Handwerk weil wir einfach
da denke ich zu wenig Durchblick haben
was wirklich wie viel hilft oder nicht
aber was schon so ist ich höre immer
zahlen und man soll bereit sein zu
zahlen
wer bezahlt denn die ganzen Steuern wer
erwirtschaftet das alles das ist die
Wirtschaft und das sind vor allem die
KMU da sind die kleinen und
mittelständigen Unternehmen das sind
irgendwie glaube ich knapp 70 Prozent in
Deutschland für verantwortlich das
Steuern gezahlt werden und die sollen
gar nicht entlastet werden die sollen
genauso entlastet werden wie der
Privathaushalt da werden Äpfel mit
Birnen verglichen und es ist letzten
Endes egal wie wir im nächsten Jahr
klarkommen der Bundeskanzler hat
mehrfach gesagt er lässt niemanden
alleine kein Unternehmen alleine er weiß
um unsere um unsere Sache er weiß wie es
uns geht und nicht nur den Bäcker wie
gesagt ich betone das immer wieder wir
sind extrem energieintensiv wir sind
aber auch extrem personalintensiv es
geht um viele viele viele tausende
Arbeitsplätze und was nützt das alles
wenn wir moralisch sind aber wir
Interessen unsere Wirtschaft und das
wird gerade also so kommt es bei uns
gerade an dass das passiert weil wir
spüren keine Entlastung ich habe einen
Kollegen der zahlt jeden Monat statt
6.75.000 Euro für Gas Abschläge sonst
wird ihm das abgedreht wer hilft ihm
niemand es gibt nicht ein Förderpaket
nichts und von heute auf morgen muss
bestimmt keiner Sanktionen wirken aber
vielleicht sollte langsam mal von heute
auf morgen einen Entlastung wirken weil
die ist einfach nicht da und wenn die
Betriebe dann reihenweise wenn wir uns
nicht wehren würden schließen weil wir
einfach nicht wie Herr Habeck das
vorgeschlagen hat mal ein paar Monate
nicht produzieren können das geht
einfach nicht außer er bezahlt uns
diesen Urlaub den wir dann hätten und
das wird er wohl auch nicht machen also
muss doch endlich mal gehandelt werden
und es dauert alles viel viel zu lange
wir reden jetzt wir massiv aus der Basis
reden seit acht Wochen unser
Zentralverband redet seit Mai und sie
wissen um die Dinge aber es passiert
nichts es passiert einfach nichts und
Geld muss da sein wenn für alles andere
Geld da ist und ich will nicht wissen
will mir das nicht Phasen wie viel
Steuereinnahmen mehr da sind durch die
Inflation warum werden wir nicht
entlastet und zwar schnell es gibt
nichts also die 300 Euro die die
Privathaushalte bekommen haben die
helfen uns gar nichts also fakt ist wir
sind alleine die Blaupause finde ich da
und zwar zu Beginn der corona-pandemie
die Soforthilfen die sind innerhalb von
wenigen Wochen aus dem Boden gestanden
die ersten Abschläge gab es auch relativ
schnell ja danach war riesen Theater
Missbrauch aber gleichwohl ich denke auf
die auf dieser Basis das hätte man dann
später gegenrechnen können man hat sich
erst schon wie gasumlage gestritten die
gaspreisbremsen Expertenkommission
überlassen und ich bin an der Stelle
völlig bei ihnen ich höre das auch aus
meinem freundes- und Bekanntenkreis
teilweise kriegst du ja gar kein
gasversorgungsvertrag mehr richtig das
ist also das heißt dann kannst du ja
Tschüss sagen kannst du die die Bude
dicht machen und da hilft auch keine
aufgemotztes Kurzarbeitergeld dann
dieser Stelle also nochmal ich finde die
Blaupausen sind da da muss man sich auch
nicht zwingend ständig an der
eu-beihilfe recht stören ich finde dann
muss man einfach machen an der Stelle
und die Dinge kann man dann später
Regeln ich kann mich noch gut erinnern
wie Olaf Scholz da ständig rumgetutet
hat zu coronazeit und Peter Altmaier an
die Wand gedrückt hat aber ich muss
sagen diese ampeltruppe die bastelt oder
sie weiß es eigentlich seit dem 24
Februar
2022 und das auf Sanktionen Putin das
Gas abdreht das war erwartbar aus meiner
Sicht also insoweit ja zwischen Februar
und heute das ist ein Dreivierteljahr
gemacht andere europäische Länder da
gibt es längst gaspreisdeckel da gibt es
längst strompreisdeckel da ist es
natürlich etwas abgemildert und ich
finde auch also es muss dringend was
getan werden ganz kurzfristig und ganz
schnell und damit die Unternehmen nicht
tot sind weil ich meine abex Idee man
macht mal Urlaub eine Weile und dann
kommt mal wieder ist eben wirklich
sehr kreativ und eben ja ein typischer
Habig aber das Grundproblem bleibt
natürlich trotzdem und das ist der
Unterschied zur corona-zeit die
corona-zeit da haben wir viel
idiotisches gemacht aber es war
zumindest immer klar es ist ein
überschaubarer Zeitraum ein Lockdown war
ein überschaubarer Zeitraum danach war
klar
ich will darauf hinaus dass es trotzdem
zu corona-zeiten klar war irgendwann ist
es wieder normal irgendwann macht man
wieder auf und wir brauchen die
Perspektive natürlich auch bei den
Energiepreisen also natürlich kann man
kurzfristig und muss man jetzt mit
staatlichem Geld da subventionieren und
unterstützen aber wir müssen ja auch
immer Bedenken auch das staatliche Geld
was dort eingesetzt wird ist das
Steuergeld was die Menschen aufbringen
also das ist natürlich auch regeltasche
Rechte Tasse und erstmal sind sehr gut
aber 20 Jahren nur Schulden machen also
irgendwann irgendwann
garantiert nicht
alles Probleme
gebracht hätte in den Griff kriegen wir
können nicht auf Dauer subventionieren
das mache ich damit auch die Einigkeit
gerade ganz schön Handlungsbedarf
Handlungsbedarf Handlungsbedarf selten
nach einer These über Russland und
Ukraine so viel Einigkeit am Tisch und
damit kommen wir zu Ihnen an ihrer Tese
heute ja ganz herzlichen Dank ich
befasse mich viel mit den USA und bin
der Meinung dass die USA ein ganz
wichtiger Partner für uns sind
wirtschaftlich wie auch politisch sie
sind ein wichtiger investitionspartner
unsere Unternehmen produzieren in den
USA amerikanische Unternehmen
produzieren hier aber sie sind eben
nicht nur ein interessenspartner sondern
ein wertepartner und wir leben ja in
einer Zeit in der das geopolitische
Umfeld immer schwieriger wird wir haben
China und Russland und viele Autokratien
auf der einen Seite wir haben
Demokratien auf der anderen wir haben
natürlich auch viele Länder in der Mitte
die unentschlossen sind auf welche Seite
sie tatsächlich gehen wollen und es
stehen letztendlich unterschiedliche
ordnungs- und Werte Modelle sich
gegenüber und in einer solchen Situation
sollten wir zusammenhalten das heißt
allerdings nicht für mich dass wir nicht
auch sehen müssen vor welchen großen
Herausforderungen die USA tatsächlich
auch stehen ein unglaublich gespaltenes
Land politisch gesellschaftlich sozial
für riesengroßen Demokratie
Herausforderungen und wir haben jetzt
gerade die mithören elections in den USA
gehabt die Republikaner haben ordentlich
aufgeholt fürs Haus der wohl für
sensitive also Repräsentantenhaus eine
rote Welle hat nicht stattgefunden aber
nichtsdestotrotz haben beiden wird
unglaublich unter Druck sein die
nächsten zwei Jahre weil er nämlich
nicht mehr aus einer Hand regieren kann
sondern die Demokraten haben definitiv
oder werden wahrscheinlich eine Kammer
verloren haben wenn ich sogar beide und
dementsprechend wird er stärker unter
Druck stehen und unab davon bin ich der
Meinung dass Europa sehr gut daran tut
die EU sehr gut daran tut wenn wir mehr
auch in eigene Wettbewerbsfähigkeit und
eigene Verteidigungsfähigkeit
investieren dazu gehört zum Beispiel
auch dass Deutschland das 2% zielerfüllt
der NATO dass wir verteidigungsfähig
auch werden aber es bedeutet eben nicht
für mich dass wir uns von den USA
abkoppeln die USA sind in ganz wichtiger
Partner also selbst die Armeen aufbauen
aber Partner der USA bleiben auf der
einen Seite unsere eigenen Interessen
verfolgen ganz klar
investieren und unsere eigene
wirtschaftliche Wettbewerbsfähigkeit
aber auch Verteidigungsfähigkeit und auf
der anderen und natürlich auch die
Probleme sehen die wir in den USA haben
und auf der anderen Seite trotzdem
versuchen so weit wie möglich mit den
Amerikanern kooperieren und die Zeit
auch mit der beiden Administrationen
jetzt noch nutzen denn wir weiß was 2024
bei den Präsidentschaftswahlen passiert
nutzen um die wirtschaftliche
Integration mit den USA voranzutreiben
was hat beiden denn bislang eigentlich
so geleistet das ist oder ist oder hat
er geleistet dass er nicht mehr Donald
Trump ist das war meine Frage die frage
ich mich schon seit längerem ja
irgendwie kam dabei mir nicht so viel
rüber also die vier Jahre unter Trump
war ja für die Europäer und für die
Deutschen wirklich ausgesprochen
schwierig nicht nur wegen des
amerikanischen da würde ich tatsächlich
sagen Handelskrieg mit China und den
steigenden Zöllen darunter hat auch die
deutsche Industrie ordentlich gelitten
sondern auch weil Trump ja Zölle auf
Aluminium und Stahl aus Europa auch aus
Deutschland am verhängt hat und immer
wieder auch mit autozüllen gedroht hat
und dadurch auch die ganze
Weltwirtschaft ganz schön durcheinander
gebracht hat also es waren wirklich
schwierige vier Jahre und mit der beiden
administrat Administration würde ich
sagen ist zum einen ein Transatlantiker
zurückgekommen der tatsächlich einen
Wert in den transatlantischen
Beziehungen auch sieht der anders mit
uns umgeht und der Ton macht eben auch
die Musik das Vertrauen ist es wieder
gestiegen und wir haben gemeinsam ein
Initiative also Europa die EU und die
USA ein transatlantischen Handels und
Technologie Rad auf den Weg gebracht wo
eben viele der Konflikte auch angegangen
werden ob nun bei
luftfahrtssubventionen oder eben bei
Zöllen und da sind wir schon auch einen
Schritt vorangekommen aber es stimmt
natürlich auch die Amerikaner verfolgen
ganz knallhart ihre Interessen im
letzten großen Gesetz was sie ja auch
erwähnt hatten im sogenannten in flation
reduction Act steckt eine Menge drin was
America first ist in der Handelspolitik
und darunter leiden natürlich auch
deutsche Unternehmen
auf dem Weg gebracht aber wer weiß
was sagen sie denn dazu dann merkt ihr
es war in Amerika Plädoyer also ich bin
kein Amerikaner und natürlich
hat man innenpolitisch die Situation
anders beurteilen ich finde wir müssen
Sie von unserer Warte aus beurteilen und
was die Außenwirtschaftspolitik und
Außenpolitik angeht muss ich sagen hat
sich unter beiden nichts wesentlich
verbessert also der der Handelskrieg
gegen China ist eskaliert also mit den
neuen Gesetzen mit den neuen Sanktionen
was ja uns indirekt betrifft weil die
USA ja immer also das ist ja auch etwas
was sich kein anderes Land dieser Welt
herausnimmt die USA machen ja nicht nur
Sanktionen die sie dann für ihre
Unternehmen vorschreiben sondern sie
schreiben sie für den Rest der Welt auch
vor das heißt auch für europäische
Unternehmen wer amerikanische
Komponenten verbaut in bestimmten
Bereichen ist jetzt auch von den
Sanktionen betroffen darf also nicht
mehr China beliefern das ist ein echtes
Problem und wie gesagt diese
subventionspakete das übersteigt ja das
was Trump gemacht hat also das wirklich
jetzt ganz konkret Unternehmen gefördert
werden die in den USA produzieren und
ausländische Exporteure entsprechend
benachteiligt werden das ist eigentlich
klassisch
reflektionismus oder wie man das immer
nennen will also mit Freihandel hat das
jedenfalls wirklich gar nichts mehr zu
tun und ich finde wir müssen eben ich
habe nichts gegen Partnerschaft im
Gegenteil die USA ist auch ein richtiger
ein wichtiger Markt für uns also
natürlich sollten wir wirtschaftlich
kooperieren aber wir müssen unsere
eigenen Interessen sehen und ich finde
europa muss wirklich aufpassen dass wir
gerade bei der kritischen Infrastruktur
nicht nur von China unabhängig sind das
sollten wir auch sein also das weiße
große Debatte Hafen und Huawei und
Bauteile da ist völlig richtig sollten
wir aufpassen dass wir nicht abhängig
werden aber noch viel abhängiger in der
ganz elementaren kritischen
Infrastruktur nämlich in der
Finanzwirtschaft und in der
digitalwirtschaft sind wir von den USA
und wir haben das damals gemerkt da ging
es um die Iran Sanktionen die Europa
nicht mitmachen wollte weil Iran ja das
Atomprogramm eingestellt hatte und
Europa war nicht in der Lage sich quasi
aus diesem
sanktionskrieg rauszuhalten weil die USA
die Macht hat über ihre Finanzwirtschaft
quasi uns das aufzuzwingen und die
digitalwirtschaft ist noch wichtiger
also in jedem Auto alles ist ist in
Zukunft Software und wenn das
amerikanische Anbieter sind dann sind
wir irgendwann nur noch die Werk
zusammenschrauber dann geht auch die die
Wertschöpfung weg also deswegen wünsche
ich mir eine europäische Politik die und
auch eine deutsche Politik die wirklich
diese elementaren Interessen sieht und
wenn ich dann immer höre wie quasi die
Geschlossenheit des westlichen
Bündnisses beschworen wird also wenn ich
das die chiffriere heißt das wir sollen
uns unterordnen und unterwürfig sein
weil das ist der Preis der
Geschlossenheit ansonsten müssen wir
eben unsere eigenen Interessen vertreten
das heißt aber dann auch mal dass es
Streit gibt das ist doch klar und wir
müssen und ich die französische Politik
ist da viel offensiver also dort wurde
diese dieser Inflation reduction ganz
anders kritisiert als bei uns bei uns
spielte das kaum eine Rolle und ich
finde das ist ein echtes Problem letzter
Punkt Verteidigungsausgaben also da muss
ich ehrlich sagen natürlich bin ich der
mein dass die Bundeswehr in der Lage
sein muss Deutschland zu verteidigen
dafür ist sie da aber ich frage mich
wieso der doch erhebliche aufwuchs im
Militäretat in den letzten Jahren nicht
dazu geführt hat dass man dazu besser in
der Lage ist sondern das offenbar das
waren ja immer die Meldungen die
Soldaten noch nicht mal irgendwie
wechselunterwäsche und Strümpfe haben
also insoweit muss ich ehrlich sagen ich
glaube es liegt nicht an der Menge an
Geld die wir in Militär investieren
sondern eher in der Art und Weise wie
dieses Geld verwendet wurde und wofür es
rausgeschmissen wurde also wir haben
wirklich gesellschaftlich wichtigere
Aufgaben als uns hochzurüsten wir haben
ein malales Bildungssystem wir haben
eine bröckelnde Infrastruktur also es
gibt wirklich viele Dinge die wir tun
sollten und wofür wir dringend Geld
brauchen weil da geht es auch um die
Zukunft als Wirtschaftsstandort
andere Länder da sehen sie bröckelnde
Infrastrukturen und es geht bei der
Bundeswehr erstmal um Ausrüstung und wir
sind wir sind meilenweit von zwei
Prozent Ziel entfernt und dann die
Aufwüchse da gibt es dann auch Inflation
und Personalkosten steigen und viele
andere Dinge mehr was wir einfach in
Deutschland an der Stelle haben
Beschaffungsbereich ich glaube da weiß
ich worüber ich rede wir sind viel zu
bürokratisch da hängen viel zu viele
Juristen drin und wenn sie mit
Frankreich ist das kein Vergleich der
französische Präsident bestimmt über die
Außenpolitik er bestimmt im
Verteidigungspolitik das wissen sie
genauso gut wie ich wir sind eine
repräsentative Demokratie und das ist
ein bisschen schwieriger bestimmte Dinge
an der Stelle durch und umzusetzen immer
noch mal auf Europa zurückkommen es
mangelt Europa nicht an Geld
in dieser Förderperiode stehen Europa
Mitten nichts Generation Fonds 1,8
Billionen Euro
nach Europa schieben sollten
wir schon richtig zuhören ich sage nur
aktuell stehen im europäischen Raum bei
den Fonds und beim next generation Fonds
rund 1,8 Billionen Euro zur Verfügung
weil beim beim Netz Generation Fonds die
Hälfte von 740 Milliarden sind Darlehen
das muss ich mal umsetzen in Europa da
muss auch Brüssel sich bewegen ich würde
den europäischen Ausflug so gerne jetzt
machen in das Problem ist wir müssen
eine ganz kurze Unterbrechung und sind
gleich wieder da und dann geht es um die
deutsche Wirtschaft bis gleich gut die
deutsche Wirtschaft
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen meine Damen und
Herren zu viertel nach acht wir haben
viel Gesprächsstoff muss das wirklich
sein das ist doch völlig
realitätsfernsehen unheimlich wichtig
vielleicht muss ich doch in die Politik
gehen ich möchte dass wir unser Land
nicht ruinieren
dass sie da vorne
in der kurzen Pause haben Herr Glööckler
und Herr Bruder sich optisch ein
bisschen angepasst das Problem ist nicht
dass wir zu wenig Stadt haben wir haben
zu viel Staaten wenn die alle wegfallen
und wir uns gegenseitig in Berlin mit
der Cappuccinos verkaufen das
funktioniert nicht dann ist mit
Wohlstand aber das ist alles Essig als
freiheitsliebender Mensch würde ich
sagen das muss jedem erlaubt sein
wenn ihr Opfer und um Währungen von
Menschen in unserem Land fordert dann
müsst ihr bei euch anfangen da muss noch
was machbar ich finde aber diese gesamte
Debatte die wir auch fühlen auch ein
bisschen verrückt das ist nicht
aufgearbeitet und das müssen wir noch
machen und das ist leider Gottes auch
ein Punkt über den wir reden soll
[Musik]
wir sind zurück und machen direkt weiter
mit dem Statement von Frau Kinder ja
vielen Dank also ganz klar ich fuhr da
für alle Lebensmittel produzierenden
Betriebe dass wir den gleichen Preis
bekommen der vorgesehen ist wie für die
Industrie denn es kann nicht sein dass
eine absolute Wettbewerbsverzerrung
stattfinden darf in diesem Bereich das
bedeutet ganz klar dass das dass die
Industrie beurteilt wird gegenüber dem
kleinen Handwerk wie es bisher
vorgesehen ist sind KMU das heißt kleine
und mittelständige Unternehmen genau so
eingestuft wie privathaushaltet das
funktioniert leider für uns nicht wir
sind sowohl energieintensiv als auch
personalintensiv und Herr Harbeck sie
müssen einfach handeln wir brauchen
jetzt Unterstützung damit wir weiterhin
nächstes Jahr backen können damit wir
regional gesunde Lebensmittel herstellen
können und damit einfach die
Arbeitsplätze viele viele Arbeitsplätze
in Deutschland erhalten
viele Dienstleister oder Firmen
Industriebetriebe die erhöhen ja einfach
die Preise und geben das dann an ihre
Handelspartner weiter und sagen dann es
tut uns leid der Gaspreis ist so sehr
gestiegen das können sie beim Brötchen
ja würde ich sagen nicht machen die
gestiegenen Preise einfach weitergeben
oder nee das funktioniert nicht mehr
weil es einfach ein riesen Kosten
Tsunami ist weil natürlich die
Lieferanten alle schon die Preise erhöht
haben dadurch dass es Corona gab das
Lieferketten unterbrochen wurden ist es
sowieso schon massiv in die Höhe
gegangen dann durch den Krieg sind die
vor allem Mehl extrem teuer geworden
also das heißt unsere Rohstoffe die
haben sich teilweise mehr als verdoppelt
massiv ist da sind alle Rohstoffe aber
massiv zu nennen ist dabei Butter gerade
und vor allem Mehl und wenn jetzt diese
Energiekosten auf uns zukommen und man
muss sagen 15 Prozent so ist geschätzt
von den backenden Betrieben sind schon
betroffen die nächsten 50 Prozent werden
im Dezember bzw Januar betroffen sein
und die anderen dann Mitte nächsten
Jahres diese massiv gestiegenen Kosten
das kann man nicht mehr an den Kunden
weitergeben weil keiner ist bereit von
Brot 1,5 oder für ein Brötchen 1,50 € zu
zahlen und falls es wäre 1,50 € pro
Brötchen wenn man die Kosten alle
weitergeben würde also ich kann es nicht
genau sagen also das ist immer ganz
schwierig die kalkulieren also wenn wir
diesen diesen Deckel der jetzt für uns
vorgesehen ist wie wir es gelegen sind
haben von der erstmal schon von der
gaspreiskommission und jetzt steht ja
auch für Strom eigentlich fest das ist
für uns auch 40 Cent sein sollen wo wir
doch von 15 kommen ich betone das immer
wieder weil es eben einige Politiker
leider nicht
dann weiß ich nicht das ist das ist so
ein Kosten Tsunami nein ich glaube nicht
dass das wir Grundversorger bleiben
können und wir sind ein Grundversorger
man darf nicht vergessen dass wir
wirklich ein Grundnahrungsmittel
herstellen und wir sind systemrelevant
und ich sage es ganz klar es sind die
Fleischer es sind die Molkereien es sind
die Müller die Müller sagen jetzt ganz
klar zu uns ja Mehl nächstes Jahr
einerseits diese horrenden Preise für
Weizen aber natürlich auch die massiv
begebenen Energiekosten also die haben
meistens Strom und dann sind wir einfach
wir kommen bei mailpreis von keine
Ahnung 35 Euro und sollen dann jetzt an
die 70 Euro zahlen schaffen sie noch die
Ladenzeiten einzuhalten also ich habe
hier ein Lieblingsbäcker um die Ecke
beim Axel-Springer-Verlag und der hat
jetzt letztes schon um 16 Uhr zugemacht
obwohl seine Zeit eigentlich bis 19 Uhr
offen ist weil er war einfach die
Mitarbeiter gefehlt haben kennen Sie das
Problem auch oder
das ist absolut so also Mitarbeiter ist
ein riesen Riesenproblem wir kämpfen
seit Jahren dass eben das Handwerk
wieder eine Revolution erlebt und das
ganz viele Menschen den handwerklichen
Beruf erlernen weil ja einfach auch so
sinnvoll ist also ich selbst bin
Lehrerin Akademiker und bin absolut
Handwerks verliebt und nicht nur in
meinen Mann sondern tatsächlich auch
wirklich in den Beruf weil ich einfach
weiß wie soll es funktionieren woher
sollen gesunde Lebensmittel kommen wenn
wir sie nicht mehr produzieren und es
sind ja nicht nur Lebensmittel sind die
Tischler wir uns fehlen so viele
Fachkräfte ja warum fehlen die warum ist
es so weil es einfach ja die letzten
Jahre medial auch glaube ich teilweise
unterstützt ich weiß es nicht genau ob
es nur daran liegt aber es ist schon der
Tenor du musst studieren sonst bist du
nichts wert und sonst kannst du auch
kein Geld verdienen und das stimmt
einfach nicht das kann man gut wenn man
fleißig ist dann funktioniert das im
Handwerk genauso aber so schwierig wie
es uns jetzt gemacht wird und dass wir
völlig vergessen werden wenn man hört
seit Wochen reden die Politiker ob es
Herr Scholz ist Herr Habeck Herr Lindner
alle sagen die Bäcker die Bäcker wir
stehen ja praktisch für den Mittelstand
sind wir das Gesicht und wie würden wir
bedacht gar nicht das funktioniert nicht
ihr dazu passt eigentlich auch die These
von Herr Rehberg heute Abend der
vielleicht eine Lösung dazu hat wie wir
wieder mehr unbefristete Arbeitsverträge
mehr Fachkräfte haben wie es der
Wirtschaft besser geht
wir haben ganz offenbar aktuell
Herausforderungen die wir am Tisch
geredet haben aber was mich seit
geraumer Zeit
umtreibt ist eigentlich das Thema human
Ressorts das gar nicht mehr Fachkräfte
Arbeitskräfte sondern wo kriegen wir
unsere human Ressourcen her und die
Prognose sagen Prognosen sagen bis 2030
5 Millionen weniger in Beschäftigung
oder werbstätige gehen raus aus der
Beschäftigung dann da ist es aus meiner
Sicht völlig kontraproduktiv ein
Bürgergeld zu initiieren die Regelsätze
sind da gar nicht mein Thema mein Thema
ist im hohem Maße ein halbes Jahr
faktisch keine Sanktion zwei Jahre kann
ich ihn schon Vermögen behalten pro Nase
60.000 viele weitere Personen 30.000 die
Wohnung kann teuer sein es werden die
kompletten Heizkosten übernommen nicht
die Energiekosten die Heiz und so weiter
und so fort und wir haben aktuell
rund eine Million arbeitslose Fachkräfte
und wir haben ungefähr 1,2 Millionen
offene Stellen in dem Bereich insgesamt
haben wir zwei Millionen offene Stellen
wobei die echte Zahl der offenen Stellen
deutlich größer sind weil gar nicht alle
gemeldet werden
Zuwanderung ist sicher ein Thema aber
nicht Zuwanderung in Sozialsysteme
sondern Zuwanderung in unseren
Arbeitsmarkt und dann dazu was auch Frau
künnete deutlich sagte ich habe mal vor
über 50 Jahren berufen oder Abitur
gemacht also ein Beruf gelernt Abitur
parallel und dann im Fernstudium meinen
Diplom als Informatiker rede ich nicht
mehr gerne drüber ist 40 Jahre her aber
gleichwohl auch zu sagen den jungen
Leuten nicht nur studieren sondern Beruf
ergreifen zweiten Bildungsweg machen und
dann mit praktischer Erfahrung auch ins
Berufsleben einsteigen auch
kennenzulernen wie es handwerkliche
Tätigkeit
und ich bin jetzt 68 Baujahr 1954 alle
meine Kumpels die Handwerksfirmen hatten
die sind in Rente in Ruhestand gegangen
ich muss jetzt zu Leuten hin und das der
nächste Aspekt die ich nicht mehr kenne
und erwarte ich eben ein halbes Jahr im
Jahr und letzte Bemerkung ich komme von
der Küste der Trend bei uns Hotel garni
also kein Restaurantbetrieb mehr mittags
ist zu ab 17 bis 21 Uhr in Schichten
Essen und so weiter und ich muss sagen
in dem Bereich
deutschsprachige Servicekräfte sind
mittlerweile sehr sehr rar gesät das
heißt einfach ich glaube diese
gesamtgesellschaftliche Debatte muss so
verschiedenen Ebenen laufen die Ebene
die Sie beschrieben haben der berufliche
Ausbildung eine duale Ausbildung zu
Meister bezahlst Du überwiegend selber
ein Studium wird überwiegend vom Staat
getragen das ist eine eine Unwucht die
wir haben oder auch wieder in Schule
einfach Lust Spaß machen auf die
MINT-Fächer und so weiter und so fort
ich und deswegen glaube ich wir gehen da
sehenden Auges in ein dilemmer rein was
eigentlich heute schon absehbar ist aber
wo aus meiner Sicht zu wenig dagegen
getan wird heute am Tisch eine Lösung
Frau Wagenknecht viele sehen sich ja
nach ihrer Partei das heißt wenn Sie
jetzt mit ihrer Partei sagen wir mal
Kanzlerin werden was wäre ihr
Lösungsvorschlag ja also ob wir gleich
in Kaiser stellen aber jetzt mal
ernsthaft zu dem Problem also ich glaube
dass wir zum einen wirklich ein
Fehlentwicklung im Bildungssystem haben
wir haben auf der einen Seite sogar
verständlicherweise den Wunsch von ganz
vielen dass sie unbedingt studieren weil
sie das Gefühl haben dass sie nur dann
einigermaßen irgendwie ein Einkommen
erwerben das heißt wir haben in vielen
und auch weil Unternehmen teilweise
natürlich lieber zumindest Abiturienten
einstellen als Leute von Real und
Hauptschulen und das verstehe ich bei
den Unternehmen sogar weil das
Lernniveau bei Real schon ein
Hauptschulen einfach so grottenschlecht
inzwischen ist dass da eben elementare
Recht Prüfung und Mathematik oder selbst
Deutschkenntnisse oft nicht vorhanden
sind wenn man mit der Schule fertig ist
aber das ist natürlich eine völlige
Fehlentwicklung also es geht ja nicht
darum dass jeder studiert sonst geht
jeder darum dass jeder eine gute
Ausbildung bekommt das leistet unser
Bildungssystem zurzeit nicht und ich
finde da muss vielmehr investiert werden
einerseits Geld aber vor allen Dingen
auch Personal es muss auch mehr
Förderung geben für Kinder aus
Elternhäusern die nicht die nicht so
unterstützt werden also da ist ganz viel
zu tun das zweite ist natürlich dass wir
auch sind die meisten Mangel Bereiche
sind natürlich Berufe wo man relativ
schlecht verdient das werfe ich jetzt
also ich kenne selber zum Beispiel
Gastwirte also die haben Restaurant und
die sind verzweifelt weil sie sagen wir
finden kein Personal wir müssen am
Wochenende zu machen weil wenn niemand
haben der da arbeitet aber es ist
natürlich trotzdem so dass man eben ja
in dem heutigen grad bei der heutigen
Inflation mit dem Gehalt wirklich nicht
klarkommt oder bei den Bäckern ist es
eben sicherlich erst recht so also man
hat ja ganz harte Arbeitszeiten man muss
also zu nachtschlafender Zeit raus
und natürlich diejenigen die dort
angestellt arbeiten da können sie nichts
dafür weil natürlich müssten sie es ja
sonst erst recht über die Kosten
weitergeben aber haben heute ein
Lohnniveau das kaum zum Leben reicht da
hat sich viel verschoben das war mal
anders also es gab diese große Kluft in
Deutschland mal nicht zwischen einem
Niedriglohnsektor der kaum zum Leben
reicht und auf der anderen Seite
spitzenverdiensten in bestimmten
Bereichen die exorbitant sind und ich
finde wir müssen das wieder schließen
also es muss tatsächlich in jedem Beruf
und gerade in handwerklichen Berufen wo
extrem auch harte Arbeit geleistet wird
muss eben insgesamt ist auch
gesellschaftlich möglich sein ein
Lohnniveau zu zahlen das Leistung
schaffen könnt wäre auch ein Weg
natürlich auch zum Beispiel Freibeträge
deutlich anzuheben und stattdessen
meinetwegen richtig Spitzenverdiener
oder sehr große Vermögen mit Millionen
oder 100 Millionen das gibt es ja alles
in Deutschland dann entsprechend
steuerlich stärker zu belasten ich meine
ich fand ja interessant dass die
Wirtschaftsweisen jetzt sagen den
Spitzensteuersatz aber da muss man auch
sagen
mit Kohlbacher bei 53%, aber er war
höher also ersetzte höher an was das
Gehalt angeht und dafür bin ich ich bin
finde das ein Bundestagsabgeordneter
durchaus ein höheren Spitzensteuersatz
bezahlen kann aber nicht ein Mittelstück
wohngesellschaften und Einzelunternehmen
und den privaten nicht unterscheiden das
lässt unser Steuerrecht nicht zu und
eins vor Wagen macht bei der Debatte
immer nicht zu vergessen wenn ich über
höhere Löhne rede dann rede ich auch
eine höhere Kosten und ein Euro brutto
sind zwei Euro Personalkosten und 3 €
Leisten
ich habe ja nur gesagt die Unehrlichkeit
ist ja immer dass die Politik natürlich
gerne erzählt wen sie alles entlastet
aber nicht gerne dazu gesagt wo das Geld
herkommen soll und das ist ja schon die
Frage die dazu gehört ich hatte noch so
schlecht sind die steuernam das
Gesamtstaates im Augenblick nicht
noch eine letzte Frage an Frau
Wagenknecht meine journalistischen Ohren
war natürlich gespitzt bei ihrer Aussage
ob wir gleich den Kanzler stellen heißt
es denn dass sie die eigenen Partei
gründen werden nein das ist noch nicht
entschieden also ich bin Mitglied einer
Partei und ich meine ich sehe dass wir
in dem politischen Spektrum das ist eine
große Lehrstelle gibt und das ist ganz
viele Menschen gibt die sich nicht mehr
vertreten fühlen und ich bedauere dass
die Partei der ich angehöre diese
Menschen offenbar nicht mehr vertritt
bzw die sich auch nicht mehr von ihr
vertreten fühlen ich halte das für ein
Problem für die Demokratie wenn immer
mehr Menschen nicht mehr zur Wahl gehen
oder aus Wut am Ende Parteien wählen die
wir uns vielleicht alle nicht wünschen
dass sie stärker werden insoweit ist
Handlungsbedarf aber es ist in
Deutschland sehr sehr schwer sowas neu
zu starten gut leider für mich keine
befriedigende Antwort am Ende das muss
auch mal seinen schönen Abend noch und
wir sehen uns morgen Abend bei 8:15 Uhr
tschüss machen sie es gut
[Musik]